[Música]
no
[Aplausos]
hay dos palabras que nos afectan a todos
la improvisación y al azar
la improvisación es ese impulso creativo
que todos tenemos con el que todos
nacimos
el azar es ese elemento desconocido
inesperado que entra jugará un papel
importante en la creación
y soy músico de jazz y constantemente me
debato entre estos dos conceptos la
improvisación
y al azar
improviso cuando tomo elementos de la
música y los combinó según mi gusto para
poder hacer una creación
cuando el azar entra en el momento que
estoy creando algo
genera un rumbo diferente algo especial
algo que yo no conozco que va a pasar
pero sucede
bach mozart y beethoven fueron grandes
improvisadores de hecho lo que conocemos
como grandes obras maestras fueron
improvisaciones que hicieron ellos
fueron tan buenas las improvisaciones
que ellos hicieron
que decidieron escribirlas
para volverlas a tocar
posteriormente a estos grandes maestros
e institucionalizando se fundan los
conservatorios
los conservatorios lo que hacen es
conservar la música para poder
transmitirla por generaciones lo cual
está bien
qué pasó tomaron estas improvisaciones
que hicieron los grandes maestros que
escribieron y las pusieron como obras
obligatorias para que las tocaran los
estudiantes de música lo cual no está
mal y todo lo hemos hecho el problema es
que el proceso creativo se dejó a un
lado
y los músicos dejaron de crear y
empezaron a tocar las creaciones de
otros
lo cual no está mal pero tenemos que
empezar a hacer lo de nosotros ahora
porque no utilizar esto en la vida
cotidiana
esto que le estoy contando detrás se
trasladó a otras disciplinas
nos toca desempeñar roles
memorizar fórmulas repetir patrones
muchas cosas diferentes una y otra vez
repetir finalmente estas cosas empiezan
a
a cortar y a minar la creatividad
y es por eso que yo vengo a proponerles
otra cosa porque no incluimos dentro de
nuestra vida la improvisación y al azar
no sabemos que el resultado tengamos
pero tal vez sea algo bueno tal vez algo
que no conocemos está esperándonos para
poder ser descubierto y quizás no sea
entregado para hacerlo por ejemplo
qué tal si yendo al trabajo cada día
escojo un camino diferente para ir
no sé qué persona conozca
tal vez pueda ayudar a alguien puedo
conocer a otra persona diferente otra
cosa que tal si por ejemplo cuando voy a
cocinar
invierto
el orden de los ingredientes para la
receta y así mismo lo podemos aplicar en
diferentes cosas porque no lo intentamos
seamos parte del cambio
ahorita vamos a la práctica que es
finalmente lo que me corresponde yo
quiero invitar a un amigo gran amigo
para mí uno de los mejores músicos de
colombia quiero invitar a jarlinsson
lozano
amigo
juntos vamos a tocar y vamos a utilizar
la sala y la improvisación para
hacer una obra y ustedes van a
presenciar algo que nunca hemos tocado
ni que se volverá a tocar
de hecho hace como tres años no tocamos
juntos así
bien
[Música]
m
bueno
cruel
a
[Música]
ah
a ver
aquí
[Música]
ah
a
aquí
[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
sí
y
[Música]
no
i
[Música]
bien
ah
[Música]
m
gracias